el calentamiento global el secuestro y
trata de personas el trabajo infantil el
maltrato animal la pobreza la
discriminación la migración los derechos
de la población lgbt
la contaminación de los océanos la
equidad de género el abandono de los
adultos mayores
las desapariciones el asesinato de niñas
adolescentes y mujeres en todo el país
cada uno de nosotros tenemos
una causa que nos mueve muchos de
nosotros tenemos una causa que nos duele
y
estos tiempos justamente ameritan que
empecemos a sembrar cada vez más
semillas de esperanza
y eventualmente en un futuro nos
permitan
justamente tener una oportunidad mejor
para todos
esta plática la nombre fútbol y
responsabilidad social
cabe mencionar que no soy experto en
fútbol por supuesto no soy experto en
responsabilidad social tampoco
tengo la fortuna de hacer lo que más me
gusta
tengo la fortuna de hacerlo al lado de
la mujer que más amo de mi esposa tengo
la fortuna de tener el apoyo de mis
padres de mis hermanos de algunos que
otros amigos que han coincidido conmigo
en el camino y hablo de fútbol porque yo
no sé si ustedes lo saben pero es el
deporte más seguido más practicado en el
mundo por mucho si yo no sé si ustedes
lo sabían pero el último evento grande
la copa del mundo de rusia 2018 fue
vista por 3.5 miles de millones de
personas eso es la mitad de la gente en
el mundo 3.5 miles de millones de
personas sintonizaron la copa del mundo
por ahí cuando entraron les regalaron
una pelotita está en su bolsa o se las
dieron en su mano por favor saquen la
cndh
justamente una pelota de fútbol
muy bien más o menos hay pelotitas para
la mitad de la audiencia sí a ver
entonces levanten su pelota y a bien
tenga un poquito logra mitad del público
que la tiene más o menos la mitad
imagínense que la mitad del mundo
estuviera involucrado en temas de
responsabilidad social deja tú la mitad
del mundo la mitad del país estuvieran
involucrados en temas de responsabilidad
la mitad de la ciudad
la mitad del lugar donde trabajas
la mitad de los que estamos en esta aula
estuviéramos involucrados en temas de
responsabilidad social imagínate qué
importantes serían los cambios que
podríamos lograr si así fuera la
responsabilidad social es la habilidad
que tenemos para responder a los retos
que se nos presentan como sociedad la
sociedad es el conjunto de indirectos
tenemos que responder como individuos
primero pero también haciéndolo en
conjunto porque si no los resultados no
se van a dar
tenemos que hacer más las causas que
acabo de nombrar multiplican las
porciones y faltan el tema en los
pueblos originarios este falta del tema
del maltrato a las mujeres falta en
muchísimos multipliquen los por cien
no se exige que nos activemos todos de
manera constante y activa por eso quiero
compartirles 3
propuestas que pueden ayudar a que
justamente se incentive la participación
de las personas
antes que eso me gustaría que
identifiquen al que no más por
apariencia o a la que no más por
apariencia parece que sería súper bueno
resolviendo cosas si identifican la
quien la audiencia volteen a verse por
favor identifiquen lo identifiquen la
una u otra o que más o menos podría
resolver algunas cosas ahora por favor
avienten de su pelotita había entonces
no de escala abren a nadie por favor
ambiente en la pelotita de esa persona
que identificaron en el público a bien
tela
la presa
es más bien tensa la otra persona ya no
importa 10 del mejor no es el
mejoramiento tu pelotita a otra persona
por favor
el sol muy bien ahí van
yo no veo muchas pelotitas flotando y
está muy bien
ahorita les voy a decir por qué hacemos
esta idea nosotros nos dedicamos en la
institución que tengo el gusto de
dirigir a la inclusión social y laboral
de personas con discapacidad hemos
tenido la oportunidad de vincular a un
poquito más de 500 personas en un empleo
si personas con discapacidad en un
empleo en un poquito más de 100 empresas
con las que estamos trabajando a lo
largo y ancho de todo el país en esta en
este andar en la inclusión laboral de
las personas con discapacidad hay una
pregunta que me hacen y es recurrente
tanto las empresas los directores las
directoras la gente de recursos humanos
los medios de comunicación y esa
pregunta es si las empresas están
contratando a personas con discapacidad
si ojo las empresas están contratando a
las personas con discapacidad y aquí
viene el tema
las empresas no tienen capacidad de
decisión las empresas es una persona
moral no tiene cabeza no tiene pies no
puedes decidir las personas no deciden
las empresas no de ciencias se contratan
las personas con discapacidad
es bien importante y este es el punto
número uno de los tres que les decía
ahorita que dejemos de aventar nos la
pelotita entre unos y otros porque a
veces pasa esto y de repente le echamos
la culpa a las empresas no las empresas
no están contratando y si no son las
empresas es el gobierno y si no es la
iglesia y si no es la policía y si no es
la
sociedad civil últimamente nos están
echando la culpa de muchas cosas y la
sociedad civil
o sea cuál es el sentido la sociedad
civil somos todos de señalar nosotros
mismos el que eres policía en un momento
al ratito es papá y al ratito es vecino
cuando terminan su turno el que siguió
lo mismo es papá ese hermano es primo es
vecino es transeúnte también no todos
somos sociedad civil en las empresas con
las que estamos trabajando para la
inclusión de las personas con
discapacidad yo te puedo le puedo poner
cara nombre y apellido a cada una de las
personas que han hecho posibles esas
contrataciones cara a nombre y apellido
te puede decir quienes abrieron camino
donde no lo había
quiénes adecuaron perfiles de puestos
quienes pusieron una rampa pusieron un
elevador para que esas cosas se lograran
eso le pudo poner nombre cara y apellido
a cada una de esas personas sí y esto es
bien importante porque el ejemplo más
claro es que cuando una empresaria
incluyente y de repente esa persona se
cambia a otra empresa
de repente mágicamente la otra empresa
de organismo incluyente no ahí está el
ejemplo de que las empresas no son
quienes contratan las personas somos
sociedad civil y nosotros
a quienes tenemos que hacer las cosas y
relacionándolo con el fútbol no lo
hacemos de manera individual como
personas messi-ronaldo
no han hecho sus equipos campeones las
elecciones nacionales no lo hacen de
manera individual tampoco lo hacen
ningún técnico no hace campeón a un
equipo ferguson pet
quien tú quieras ganando uno que otro
pero el trabajo es el que se hace en
equipo y entonces podemos hacer que las
las cosas cambien tenemos que dejar de
aventar nos la pelotita es la idea
número uno la idea número dos es que
tienes que saber que no estás obligado a
participar eso es bien importante porque
luego a veces nos abruma que hay tantas
cosas en las que tenemos que hacer y
entonces no participamos porque son
tantas cosas no estás obligado ni a
hacerlo ni aportar a ninguna de las
causas esto es bien importante saberlo
él te voy a dar un ejemplo bien sencillo
hay tiendas de conveniencia en las que
te invitan a hacer una dinámica que se
llama redondeo si en este redondeo lo
que sucede es que tú vas y pagas dos
centavos que sobran te invitan a que
lorre donde es y lo que pasa es que esa
empresa entrega lo recaudado a una
institución el chisme que anda por ahí
rondando es que la empresa se beneficia
porque nosotros instituciones les
entregamos un recibo deducible de
impuestos y entonces ellos dejan de
pagar impuestos si eso es más falso que
todo en la vida nosotros hemos sido
beneficiados por el redondeo y en ningún
momento se les ha entregado a ninguna de
esas empresas un recibo a nombre de
ellas en ningún momento y así como
nosotros 20 25 30 50 instituciones en
san luis potosí jamás les han entregado
un recibo deducible de impuestos
entonces tenemos que saber y este es el
punto número 2 que no destruir también
suma
es bien importante que no difundamos
información falsa que no hagamos chismes
puede ser por la razón que quieras te
vio mal te vio feo el cajero del oxxo o
de atedy ya le dijiste a 25 cajeros que
no quieres donar y entonces el 27 tiene
hasta el gorro y entonces le dices que
no y explota si empiezas a difundir
chismes que no son ciertos no destruir
también suma no destruyas si estás
si estás interesado en que las cosas
mejoren el punto número 3 es que si ya
te decidiste involucrar en alguna de las
causas o cosas en las que crees que
puedes aportar algo positivo
hazlo fácil como el fútbol si yo creo
que el fútbol es tan seguido y tan
practicado en el mundo porque las reglas
son super sencillas no tienen chiste
cuáles son las reglas
gana el que mete más goles cierto los
goles valen un punto no valen dos ni
tres ni seis ni siete valen un punto
también fácil contar de uno en uno
no se vale usar las manos más que el
portero es la regla número dos necesitas
una portería y un balón
ese es el tercer punto y a veces la
portería mira la marca es así o mira de
ahí ahí esa es la portería ni siquiera
necesitas una portería física y el balón
es fácilmente sustituido por una piedra
o por una plata o por una botellita de
pet o lo que sea yo creo que el fútbol
es tan seguido porque las reglas son
bien fáciles de seguir
entonces si nos involucramos en alguna
causa social tenemos que hacer lo fácil
para que otros se involucren darles la
oportunidad de que se enamoren de que
vibren de que brinquen de que hagan
cosas de que le entiendan de manera
sencilla nadie de los que nos
involucramos en alguna causa nadie
empezamos a viéndolo todo
ninguno de nosotros y eso esto es bien
piensen si bien fácil bien importante de
hacer tenemos que hacerlo pasitos de
bebé pasitos de bebé poquito a poquito
para que las cosas empiecen a fluir y
entonces enamoremos a más gente y esa
gente pueda enamorar más gente porque
acuérdate que mientras más fans más
acción el fútbol 3.5 miles de millones
de personas
mientras más fans más acción en
cualquier cosa que hagas es bien
importante que hagamos más fans y esos
fans se logran solamente si le entienden
a las cosas si tú me preguntas si puedo
ser fan del lacrosse o del cricket o de
cualquier otro deporte totalmente yo no
lo entiendo no me dado el tiempo de
meterme y nadie ha venido a platicar me
compasión de qué se trata ese deporte
no me enamoraba ahora si lo haces fácil
a lo mejor más gente se involucra y
entonces a lo mejor logramos más cambios
más rápido para resumir los tres puntos
encuentra tu causa
la que te mueve
para que te duele
involúcrate si no quieres involucrarte
en nada se vale si se vale
lo que no se vale es destruir no
destruir también schümann
y si decides involucrarte hazlo fácil
como el fútbol
apasionante vibra lo
tú has visto a esa gente que vive y
grita y soy brinca el sillón y hace
todos los planes toda la semana se pasa
planeando cuando vas a ir a ver el
fútbol el sábado o el domingo
imagínate que así fuera
para hacer cosas en temas de
responsabilidad social o en causas
sociales mientras más fans más acción
la forma en la que
en el fútbol definimos
que un equipo es el mejor
es con el trofeo de la copa del mundo no
y levantamos un trofeo el tema con la
situación actual
es que nos exige que nos demos cuenta de
que no es sólo una copa el mundo y no la
vamos a ganar una vez en un momento en
el futuro son un chingo de copas del
mundo todos los días a todas horas y en
todos los lugares
y tenemos que irlas ganando todos los
días para poder estar en un lugar mejor
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]